wish you could add ai to your
application but have no background in
making machine learning models
are you worried it's going to take you
too much time and energy just to get
started well i've got great news for you
you can enable ai in your applications
in seconds that's because google cloud
has already done the hard work for you
and in this video i'll show you how
[Music]
yes it's true that it can take a long
time and lots of data to build a good ai
model
if you start from scratch that is but
why reinvent the wheel when you can have
the state of the art at your fingertips
google has a long history of publishing
at the forefront of ai research and
we've made our best models available to
you at the click of a button
our pre-trained apis give you instant
access to the ultimate ai toolbox
allowing you to jump right in to
building ai-powered applications without
having to go through years of gathering
your data learning the ai tech training
your own models tuning them retraining
them instead
simply select from our library of
machine learning apis to access the best
machine learning models in the world
these include models for computer vision
speech models that work with over 70
languages and 137 language variants
language translation models speech
transcription sentiment analysis speech
synthesis and so much more the
possibilities are endless and unlike the
models that you'd build from scratch you
won't need to constantly keep them
updated because we're doing that for you
these models never go out of fashion as
we're constantly innovating and
implementing the latest breakthroughs
from deepmind google research and ai
publications and in this video i'm going
to show you how to enable speech to text
a popular api that processes over a
billion voice minutes per month for our
enterprise customers but keep in mind
that enabling our other apis is also
quick and easy we have a whole library
of apis for you to explore and build
with to put your app on the leading edge
of innovation without further ado
let's dive in i've just started a free
trial with a new account and here i am
on google cloud platform dashboard think
of that as your project's home page
we're looking at the first thing you'll
see when you start up your google cloud
console
so how do we get that state of the art
speech to text api enabled go through
this hamburger navigation menu and
scroll here to speech to text click and
then you'll click enable the api
all right click enable the api and
congratulations you're ready to start
adding ai powered speech transcription
to your app
so let's create a transcription in this
demo we'll grab a file of my laptop with
a local upload but where are we
uploading it to we'll need a storage
bucket to store our files on google
cloud if you've already got a project
going chances are you've already got
your storage bucket set up and you can
just point to it but in case you don't
i'll go ahead and take us through making
a quick bucket in here you can name
yours whatever you like
i'll name mine my first bucket tts and
add a bunch of zeros there now we've got
the storage bucket and we can quickly
set up our workspace from that okay
select create
now we can do a local upload hit browse
there's my sample audio file and you can
see that the information from the
metadata is already read in so there's
nothing for us to fill out here now what
language do i speak english but what
accent what dialect ah i'm not so sure
myself i've lived in a lot of places but
i grew up in south africa so let's try
south african
good luck to you api and now we can just
hit submit and see the results
perfect it's as easy as that
and in an upcoming video i'll show you
how to do this with code so you can
automate transcription for many files at
once and we'll also look at how to blend
apis together but in the meantime head
over to our google cloud homepage to try
it out yourself today free of charge
[Music]
[Music]
you